ابراج الفيروز هذه المنطقه التي تتميز
بالبنايات السكنيه العاليه الان هذه
المنطقه مدمره بشكل كامل بعد انسحاب قوات
الاحتلال منها نرصد هذا الدمار الكبير من
داخل منطقه ابراج الفيروز البنايات التي
تحوي عشرات العائلات من داخل هذا المكان
الان هي عباره عن اكوام من
رماد هذه منطقه ابراج الفيروز المكونه من
اربع ابراج سكنيه ضخمه جدا هذه المنطقه
الان مدمره هي ومحيطها كل البنايات
السكنيه الواقعه في محيط هذا المكان هي
عباره عن اكوام من رماد قوات الاحتلال
احدثت الخراب الخراب الكبير والدمار ايضا
الكبير في هذه المنطقه زنزال اكبر من
زنزال بدك تقول دمار اكبر من دمار ولا دار
على اختها ولا شارع تعرف شارع زفته كنا
نمرق منه
زمان هذه احنا سكنا في البيت هذا في سنه
73 يا باشا في 73 فاهم علي 73 هذا كان في
اسفلت وكان شوارع ومنطقه ومدينه يعني ارقى
منطقه في قطاع غزه كانت منطقه النصر هذا
جامع الشنطي هذا كان دوار هنا شارع هنا
بيطلع هيك على ضرابيه هنا بطلع هيك على
الابراج يعني ما فيش شي غايل على ما هو يا
ابن عم الان هذه الابراج هي مدمره ولا
يستطيع احد البقاء في هذه المنطقه او
الوصول اليها لان سبل الحياه معدومه في
داخل هذه المنطقه والله لا يوصف دمار بحت
طبعا زي ما انتم شايفين الضمار هذا تفجير
تمام مره واحده اجيت اليوم بطلع ما فيش
دورش يعني اي حاجه بخ ح اصلا
يعني الناس ساكنين هنا يعني يشوف المنظر
يمكن يعني مش عارف احكيلك يعني الكلام لا
يوصف بدي احاول احكي
ايش مش قادر
هذه منطقه مسجد ابو بكر الصديق هي مدمره
بشكل شبه كامل للاسف الكثير من البنات
السكنيه سقطت واخرى احرقت في هذا المكان
بفعل قوات الاحتلال حتى الشوارع لم تسلم
البن التحتيه مدمره شبكات الكهرباء شبكات
الاتصال شبكات المياه شبكات الصرف الصحي
الدمار في كل
مكان